this is Tesla's Model S and we're going
to have a look at how autopilot actually
works we'll do the hardware first while
we're outside underneath the plastic
front bumper cover here is a radar that
can look forward range of several
hundred meters so the car can tell
what's in front of it that data is
combined with information from these
little dots there are 12 of them around
the entire circumference of the car
their ultrasonic sensors so a much
shorter range but more of them up here
at the top of the windscreen is a camera
that's forward-facing and there's also
very high precision GPS so the cars
computer knows exactly where it is all
the time while we're still in park we
can actually activate autopilot or the
parts of it we go into settings here
it's this control up at the top auto
steer brackets beater I'm going to press
on just one of those ones you tend to
gloss over Tesla really wants us to read
this now it's saying I will keep my
hands on the wheel
do I want to enable auto steer while it
is in beta and say yes and that's it
that's on lane changes on already start
a trip we're on the freeway here in
Nevada so this is the type of situation
where autopilot should work and so first
I'm going to pull this lever towards me
once that activates adaptive cruise
control something that a lot of cars
have these days I have it set at 70 the
truck in front of us is only doing 62
miles per hour right now so the car
won't go any faster than that but if I
manually change lanes and we go around
the truck and take my foot back off the
accelerator the car is now doing 70 and
it will hold 70 less there's something
in front that the radar sensors that
means that we have to slow down
the second part of autopilot is the auto
steer now that I have to pull the lever
twice to activate there we go and it
comes up with a little sign there saying
please keep your hands on the wheel but
I can just keep one hand on now because
I can see in the display here that I
have two lines highlighted in blue that
means the car is seeing both lane
markings on either side if we were
closer to that vehicle in front that's
up there then that would also be in blue
saying that the car recognizes that it's
there it's kind of locked onto it as a
leading signal we can just cruise along
like this I'm supposed to keep hands on
the wheel but you can see how relaxing
it does feel it lulls you into this
sense of security
another fun function of autopilot and
right now in the left hand lane I should
be in the right hand lane I'm just going
to activate the signal and then I'm
actually gonna take my hands off the
wheel here altogether just to show you
the car just moved across into the other
Lane owners even exit there which it has
managed not to send us down and it's now
centered us back into the right-hand
lane not entirely sure how useful that
function is it's nice that it checks
your blind spots for you and that will
perhaps get better over time the
software right now I personally give a
very tight eye on the car whenever it's
changing lanes just to make sure it's
doing it the way that I wanted to
this is a great time to be using
autopilot we're in a line a very
slow-moving traffic here although we're
on a highway that's got a speed limit of
65 which the camera has captured and is
showing me in front here now you can see
the speed is going up and down I
actually don't have my feet on the
pedals right now I will keep one hand on
the steering wheel because that's what
we're supposed to do but the car is just
speeding up and slowing down as the car
in front the car in front is braking I'm
not touching the pedals with my feet I
just have one hand on the wheel the car
is going to slow down as aircraft slows
down we would come to a complete stop
and then start moving again so in
stop-and-go traffic really take some of
the pressure off the driver one thing
that it's not liking here if you can see
outside the driver's window here we're
in the left-hand Lane and there's a
concrete rail that runs very very close
to the side of the lane and autopilot is
displaying these yellow markings in
front of me warning that there's
something there something in my blind
spot that's kind of triggering it the
whole time if we were going any faster
than the 20 miles an hour or so we're
crawling along at I'd probably be
driving manually just because I would
feel more control with that
and one little easter egg Tesla
engineers have left us you click six
times on this leader
you get the Rainbow Road from Mario Kart
and a little burst of more cowbells from
SNL apparently favorites of Elon Musk